and i also have to ask you about uh your  reaction how you felt after  your win against magnus carlsen  went viral made the headlines everywhere  and you had names like sachin  who tweeted the  prime minister of india also tweeted  how did you feel i mean  with this all this attention yeah it was  uh great to see so many people following  just is definitely good for chess in  india and now there is olympiad also so  there will be more people following and  taking up chess as professional sport  yeah and uh for me yeah it was good i  got a lot of attention but  yeah i just try to uh not focus too much  on that just try to focus on the game  and work harder  yeah yeah just how i i used to do  earlier yeah